cela aurait pu être une histoire d'amour
banale entre un garçon de 20 ans et son
amie de 17 ans au milieu de l'été le
jeune homme part avec elle quelques
jours de liberté au retour leur vie va
basculer
il l'aura c'est parce qu'elle voulait se
marier avec moi
on voulait être mari et femme et ils ne
l'ont pas acceptée on a vu la maison
pendant quelques jours en espérant qu'il
se ferait à l'idée que je puisse être
leur gendre parce que moi je suis d'une
autre confession
je suis chrétien eux sont musulmans
c'est pour ça qu'ils ne m'ont pas
accepté ils nous ont dominés ils nous
ont beau biner pour revenir à la maison
quand on est rentré à la maison ça a été
le cas au général ils ont commencé à la
frapper à lui couper les cheveux à lui
demander pourquoi elle voulait se marier
avec moi pourquoi elle a choisi un
chrétien comme épouse si j'avais été un
musulman il n'y aurait pas eu de
problème à ce moment là je ne savais pas
trop comment réagir
je suis vite sorti et j'ai appelé la
police
la jeune fille vit séparé de ses parents
désormais elle sera présente demain au
tribunal
je sais pas comment je vais supporter
tout ce qui bougeait un peu stressé à
cause de ma famille de parler car je
veux juste d'être nous pensons qu'il
faut qu'il soit puni de façon la plus
sévère
les parents que nous avons aussi
rencontré ont exprimé des regrets ils
sont sous le coup d'une procédure
d'expulsion
les deux amoureux espère continuer leur
vie en france